on this episode we talked which Mike
Tyson's punch-out and Zelda but it's not
a video game show
[Music]
this is
Gary B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 131 on
the ask gary vee show first I want to
say sid i love you this is it for the
summer I'm actually devastated that
you're leaving so thanks for being here
for the summer I want to say that the
golden era is over and we are now going
into the dark ages and and I'm really
looking forward to it I'm about to spend
a lot of time with my family so the show
the show will be a little more
infrequent here towards the end of
August into through Labor Day so you're
going to realize how much you love this
thing you know the heart grows fonder
Steve you know Steve and I and the
people at Wine Library have been working
flip it Steve we are working hard core
do you reckon up to zoom in let's make
an image for it overlaying so it looks
better see much easier at wine deals on
Instagram the only way to buy wine in
America period yeah I'm excited about it
so now we're hacking you know I'm
excited for this being a business
context show first of all if you love
wine at all or into it or buy wine at
the supermarket you should check it out
because we're being ridiculous I'll be
very transparent of it with you the
first hundred days of deals are gonna be
much much better than later on because
I'm trying to win early on so it's
getting great that's shutting off the
pop thing you bought was sick number two
I'm gonna be able to and I'm learning in
real time remember the thing I take the
most pride in is I'm a practitioner we
are learning a ton about Instagram
commerce and I'll be sharing those
things with you might be a good idea to
ask questions about Instagram commerce
going forward India you and I were just
talking before we started the show about
rounding out and finishing up the
askgaryvee book so we're gonna be coming
to you on facebook and instagram on the
feed to ask questions around certain
categories so you'll be seeing that
shortly that's exciting
yesterday we spoke in Hoboken that was
good talk right was there some new stuff
oh I don't have time I don't have money
what was me it's a couple of different
things I'm it's always the same but stop
watching the entire seasons of in you
know house of cards there's some stuff
I don't give a [ __ ] I was right oh yeah
do you rock we got some good stuff for
footage right literally like really like
you've got time for Angry Birds and
you're complaining get out of here
awesome so alright India what else I
want oh oh I need to give us I need to
do some outright hooking for my homies
at vaynermedia South by Southwest this
would be the first time that I'm not the
only one speaking a bunch of the
vaynermedia people have submitted panels
but they need vote see unlike me who's a
boss let right stay with me let's do it
boss together say boss okay unlike me
who's just gets slotted in because I can
draw these characters at Vayner need
some votes to actually get their panels
selected right so Dirac let's link it up
for them in Facebook and YouTube
don't forget because you forgot the
Facebook link the other day yes okay
thank you dear uck
don't forget the links when you're
editing and watching you should just
don't but anyway and and so when we have
like three or four different panels
right yeah so you could yes so I would
appreciate it that would make them
really feel happy they've been asking me
for a little love can you tweet no I'm
not gonna tweet I'm gonna and I'm gonna
I'm gonna activate the vaynernation and
so I know you guys will come through for
them and so that means a lot to me if
I'd be like emoji that does this right
here I would do that my snapchat game my
snack isn't a fact you know what the two
in real-time might see this was a clever
kind of content play my snapchat game is
a my snapchat game is really leveling up
said Andrew India Steve so I'm enjoying
that the snapchat stuff has been fun um
and that's it that's kind of my roundup
just start the show oh thank you yes you
know I don't know if you like cool
stickers on laptops clearly stunwin does
but this might be a very good thing to
go check out a lot of you are taking
advantage of that a bunch of you are
just not smart enough to take advantage
of it I laugh and mock your intellect
and so that's that and so alright India
let's get into the show the show gotta
mix it up right Terrell asks how would
you manage pro bono work versus getting
paid as a start-up or how do you draw
the line between the two I think I think
the question I think what I'm getting
from it is you know where how do you
manage the people asking you to do stuff
on spec and it's funny we've had some
conversations through yeah I'm a fan of
spec because I think it's a gateway drug
into into showing work when you're at
zero when you have no track record when
you have no leverage spec is a
tremendous opportunity or at-bat and and
and so where spec has always been
interesting is in design work or other
things of that nature any time I even
allude to a spec interplay on Twitter I
get attacked right like if I want free
t-shirts like for the great wall of wine
deals like right old stickers like why
don't you pay for them I'm thrilled to
pay in fact in my later years aka the
last three years I've learned actually
I'd rather pay than what I deal with
when somebody gives you like a sticker
for free and they want like you know
like so I'm into paying I actually look
I actually when I do these spec things
look at it as the first opportunity to
somebody to have an opport
in at bat to like change the course of
their game we have a little this
question answer with what T rock in the
past like this is just real to me so
where do you draw the line is when you
stop thinking it brings you value by the
way nobody's forcing you into doing pro
bono work hey d-roc you want to make a
film with me you should do it I'm not
gonna pay you you should do it I didn't
force him like you know that's on you so
this notion of pro bono work being like
some sort of forced behavior that like
the rich are forcing the poor to do this
work in a world where you should always
do everything predicated on what brings
you value including when you bring other
people value see the dirty little secret
is for me this 5149 thing where I want
to do all these things it makes me feel
good it might not make me more money it
makes me feel good
it's a selfish act people say that you
know year it's like oh it's a selfless
act like I understand I like the way it
feels and so you know your pro bono work
might be because you want to use it as a
gateway drug to business opportunities
in the future or you just might like the
way it feels that's on you but you know
business is simple and it's a business
show in the scheme of things so I expect
this to be where you're coming from
look you have to ask here you can't be
scared to ask for money you have to ask
and you have to price yourself and you
have to price yourself in a way that
makes you feel good and so whether
that's $100 an hour $500 an hour and the
other thing I would tell you is let the
market say no I think a lot of people
are too scared to go too high and we
talked about this on another show not
too long ago like you know just ask for
the money and go as high as you possibly
can they can always say no they're not
never to say it's gonna cost you five
hundred dollars for your art you know
anything five hundred dollars for your
voiceover works done you know I want
$100 an hour nobody's gonna say cool
we're gonna give you 125 and so you know
you're better off saying 200 like I will
give you 120 you're like yes I only
wanted 100 thanks Gary B you like that
100 in the we were idiots
sure the good job picking up on what I
was referring to you are pissing me off
India I told you yesterday
do not forget you just were like we were
gonna wear our shove t-shirts I don't
know I don't even even open my boxes but
it was gonna be you wearing it that was
gonna remind me I know said you want to
go and get it but don't worry about it
let's keep going nope said you sit here
let's go green talk asks I notice that
NJ tech that your staff was really young
I didn't see anybody over 40 surrounding
you why well India is actually 44 she
just looks phenomenal I mean so there's
that you know yeah my staff is young you
know I think I get a value out of
mentoring though mentoring a lot of
people now that are
or in their 30s and 40s and 50s yeah my
team happens to be young I'm not really
I'm more than open to hiring anybody
race credence you know like anything
just it just hasn't happened the
company's young I mean like you know
like you know look it's kind of one of
these things like stereotypes there's
some truth to it look I mean this
company started doing social media
marketing in 2009 10 11 like the 60 year
olds weren't rolling in you know and so
you know I just you know I think a lot
of people overthink these things meaning
like you know for example a lot of
people a lot of people around me are
always like wanting me to stage things
for photos for interviews for on my team
you know like all this stuff like I'm
aware that India's the female MIT like
I'm a winner of stuff like I'm aware of
everything like I just also think
authenticity rules and so you know - I'm
answering your question in the question
that's the broader question you know I'm
pumped to have anybody on my team listen
and they blow up test this I love
standing in front of the company and
saying look I'm 39 I'm the old man I
think I'm better at social media than
all of you like I'm not I don't I truly
believe that like I don't prejudge on
age sex where you're from well actually
I do judge a little bit from where
you're from meaning if you're from the
streets I do value you more I do like a
little bit of the grind than the hustle
it's an absolute truth it's so funny the
true one place where I think more than
the cliche things of age or sex or race
where I'm a little prejudiced is I like
value the streets I just do the streets
aka just struggling I just I'm a fan of
it anyway yeah just it's been the
serendipity of it you know the team has
been built from people almost a little
bit less actually that's not true like
India and Steve were here and I guess I
guess the rest of the team so for were
hot Zak was hard for so yeah so yeah
it's an interesting thought like I'm
into it I I'm super into it apply
doc Sheldon right I love doc you know
doc is hardcore Earlywine live do you
remember with doc in my life yeah doc is
the man
valentina asks what's the next big move
for Facebook to keep its content
creators from switching over if Facebook
starts sharing its revenue - I don't
think there's a move for it being
either/or I think all YouTube stars will
be on both and I think in two years
there'll be people that come from
Facebook and I'm actually thinking about
betting more on YouTube lately in a
weird way and I feel like like I went
like I'm Andy rock made a face it's
because you know I'm uh I feel like I
understand what I want to do read them
wise in Facebook and like from an ad
targeting and from a Content standpoint
they're like I'm like huh under like the
you know YouTube's easy there's a lot of
people have already achieved it they're
like it's like this wonderful gal who's
gonna be who I met in LA that you guys
are going to talk to you about the
Facebook group she's been jamming on it
for seven years that's established I
have like it's actually fun to go into
something established because there's
some sort of blueprint and you can just
jam on it so I think that uh I think
that uh
YouTube will lose some of its stars to
sharing on Facebook because it's about
reach the reason YouTube stars like
being on television even though they're
digital natives is it just more
awareness like that's if you're a
YouTube star that's what you want like
you want more people watching you right
and there's a lot of eyeballs on
Facebook and when these YouTube stars
stop getting romantic about YouTube and
being sad and realize how targeted they
can be on who they reach on Facebook
they will be a-coming and so it's not
going to be about what they can do and
look then you get into a networks war
like the platforms are becoming the
network's the Internet is the whole pipe
and then there's the platforms that are
networks
so imagine YouTube and and Facebook and
snapchat like NBC Fox and CBS you can do
something about it YouTube you're gonna
have to pay moody pie you know a
trillion dollars to stay exclusive so
that's gonna be very interesting I know
it's pretty bad
[Music]
to the Golden Age of the askgaryvee show
with this war my question my question to
you is if you believe in the influencer
market all the companies that are coming
up with amazing stats around athlete to
use that data to start play marketing
Moneyball with their teams love to hear
your thoughts on thank you for giving
back
marketing Moneyball right yes will will
sports teams use data to make better
marketing decisions yes and I and I know
that I'm like keeping a basic but like
personal cool last video
second of all very basic question
meaning all of marketing will use data
to make better decisions Moneyball is
the notion of using data in baseball
data is going to be used in every part
of our world everywhere forever
marketing happens to be one of them
dating is you know like if you think
about like like oh anyway
dating with one of them a lot of things
a lot of things will be that way and so
I think that data will be overlaid
across everything and and marketing is
actually already here and there are
teams doing it already and we've done
stuff like that for the Jets and the
Dolphins already so yes Joe asks can you
explain to my 13 year old son that
meerkat and periscope are dominating
streaming while twitch is being left in
the dust Joe I can't do that my friend I
actually think your 13 year olds got
your number here my friend
so twitch which plays in the esports
kind of realm in my opinion is
dramatically bigger than meerkat and
periscope where they have figured out
their content very easily which is it is
now a foregone conclusion that millions
of people will sit for trillions of
hours and watch other people
that is done sober now we are in the
beginning stages of that 100% meaning in
20 years more people watch the eSports
championship than the World Series and
it may not even be close so you know I
think your 13 year olds got your number
mister now will there be personalities
that breakout on periscope meerkat
Facebook live and have real great things
happen
absolutely but which you know it's a
concise value prop and so it's kind of
like ESPN versus NBC NB C's at the mercy
of original content and stars breaking
through because they can go anywhere aka
meerkat and periscope twitch is very
full down into this is the value prop
and it's a big space
Allah ESPN like people like sports it's
got its niche it's there I actually
think he's got you cooked it's actually
not even close
I think you're a 13 year old Punk you in
the face what do you think Steve you
expressed it you watch a lot of I watch
more Twitch any other how many hours a
week
oh god I tell you fire me go ahead no I
mean tell the truth like when I tell me
show that real I'm really curious on
things that's on my second monitor like
just as like somebody we stop patching
Steve I don't know what no no by the way
it's pretty amazing though he's sport
III I am you know in my venture capital
behavior eSports is now at the top I'm
I'm a big fan so anyway good show I like
this new like this is a new year as we
know and that are we gonna era at least
I don't want to do nowhere here will
never say the word era again era just
kidding okay question on the day what is
your all-time favorite video game non
mobile games that's a whole nother space
I actually think that's gonna be a thing
but video game Council classic not even
PC which is considered much more
respectful but um an average
gamer type of guy you know like Nintendo
second Genesis you know that kind of
stuff
Oh India what's your all-time favorite
video game very nice
true I'm what not I'm Nintendo what you
mean - Tendai 64 yeah right yeah well
you know you're so young you think man
you think Nintendo 64 is Nintendo now
you discuss sit FIFA on what year so my
the current one okay stun huzza good
uncut asked me to consult yes yes or
anything what did you said Wow the
Citizen Kane of video games
Wow I know it's super respected I've
seen 11 remember I'm this ice to buy
these games at garage sales and flip
them so I've got a good understanding
which leads me to my answer which is
Mike Tyson's punch-out it's just it was
such a that christmas and hanukkah was
early that year so I had at first it was
like you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
[Music]
you
[Music]